it may be September but a major winter
storm is expected to hit the Northern
Rockies with heavy snow high winds and
even blizzard conditions Montana is
already starting to feel the effects
this morning and parts of the state
could receive more than three feet of
snow this week the storm is expected to
be a historic one potentially bringing
daytime temperatures more than 30
degrees below seasonal averages
meanwhile thunderstorms in Eastern
Illinois unleashed heavy rain and winds
that caused this Oktoberfest celebration
to be evacuated about 50 miles south of
Chicago
Jeff Baer Adelie joins us with the rest
of the nation's weather Jeff good
morning good morning tarika good morning
everyone fall is coming in with a big
bang across the country so we have this
big dip in the Jetstream
winters forcing its way south summer is
trying to cling on for dear life in the
southeast and it's doing a very good job
and because of this we have this seesaw
effect in the jet stream so what goes
down must come up or what goes up must
come down and so it's driving winter
south into the Northwest in the east we
expect 200 daytime highs over the next
week about 200 record warm morning low
so it's gonna be sweltering in the
northwest a historic blizzard
temperatures 30 degrees below normal and
in between rounds of severe weather
where they do battle so you can see how
much snow we're gonna see and it's
amazing because the lower elevations
around a foot but higher elevations
around 2 to 4 feet wind gusts to 60
miles an hour 4 feet of snow in the
beginning of October and in the east a
sweltering heat wave we're gonna see
temperatures probably 90 to 100 degrees
feels like temperatures probably as high
as a hundred plus and we're gonna worsen
a drought in the southeast and across
the East we're also gonna see the peak
or apex of this heat wave likely occur
on Wednesday with actual high
temperatures in the mid 90s as far north
as Washington DC it's gonna swelter for
at least the next week in the East so
hold on a second Jeff four feet of snow
yes in the northwest and 95 degrees in
Atlanta this is why I get paid
employed that all the way I think about
well well done sir what a crazy weather
pattern Jeff thank you very much